Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Se han quedado varados
a miles de kilómetros de casa
sin dinero ni posesiones.
Tal situación provocaría desesperación
y que muchos maldigan su horrible destino.
Pero para Zenón de Citio
se convirtió en la base de su trabajo
y el legado de su vida.
El mercader una vez rico perdió todo
cuando naufragó en Atenas
alrededor del 300 a.C.
Sin mucho por hacer,
entró en una librería,
leyó sobre Sócrates y quedó intrigado,
y empezó a buscar y estudiar con
los filósofos famosos de la ciudad.
Conforme Zenón empezó a educar
a sus propios estudiantes,
sentó las bases de la filosofía
conocida como estoicismo,
cuyas enseñanzas sobre la virtud,
la tolerancia y el autocontrol
han inspirado a generaciones
de pensadores y líderes.
La palabra "estoicismo"
viene del griego "stoa poikile",
la columnata pública decorada
donde Zenón y sus discípulos
se reunían para las tertulias.
Hoy, usamos la palabra
"estoico" coloquialmente
para referirnos a alguien
que permanece tranquilo bajo presión
y evita extremos emocionales.
Pero si bien esto refleja aspectos
importantes del estoicismo,
la filosofía original era
más que solo una actitud.
Los estoicos creían que
todo a nuestro alrededor
funciona de acuerdo con
una red de causa y efecto
cuyo resultado era una estructura
racional del universo llamada logos.
Y aunque no siempre podemos controlar
los eventos que nos afectan,
sí podemos tener el control
sobre cómo abordamos las cosas.
En lugar de imaginar una sociedad ideal,
el estoico intenta lidiar
con el mundo tal cual es
mientras persigue su desarrollo personal
a través de cuatro virtudes cardinales:
la sabiduría práctica,
la capacidad de enfrentarse
a situaciones complejas
de una manera lógica,
fundamentada y tranquila;
la temperancia,
el ejercicio del autocontrol
y la moderación
en todos los aspectos de la vida;
la justicia,
tratar a los demás con imparcialidad
incluso cuando han errado
y valentía,
presente no solo
en circunstancias extraordinarias,
sino al enfrentar desafíos diarios
con claridad e integridad.
Como escribió Séneca, uno de los
más famosos escritores romanos,
"Algunas veces incluso vivir,
es un acto de coraje".
Pero si bien el estoicismo
se centra en la mejora personal,
no es una filosofía egocéntrica.
En una época en que las leyes romanas
consideraban a los esclavos una propiedad,
Séneca pidió un trato humano para ellos
y enfatizó que todos compartimos
la misma humanidad fundamental.
El estoicismo tampoco
fomenta la pasividad.
La idea es que solo los que cultivaron
la virtud y el autocontrol
pueden despertar
un cambio positivo en otros.
Uno de los escritores estoicos más famosos
fue uno de los grandes
emperadores romanos.
El estoicismo ayudó a Marco Aurelio
durante el curso de su reinado de 19 años
a liderar el Imperio enfrentando
dos guerras importantes
y a afrontar la pérdida
de muchos de sus hijos.
Siglos más tarde, los diarios de Marco
guiarían y consolarían a Nelson Mandela
durante sus 27 años de prisión
durante su lucha
por la igualdad racial en Sudáfrica.
Después de su liberación
y eventual victoria,
Mandela enfatizó la importancia
de la paz y la reconciliación,
convencido de que si bien las injusticias
del pasado no podían cambiarse,
su pueblo podía
confrontarlas en el presente
para construir un futuro
mejor y más justo.
El estoicismo fue una escuela
de filosofía activa
durante varios siglos en Grecia y Roma.
Desapareció como institución formal,
pero sigue siendo
una filosofía influyente.
Los teólogos cristianos,
como Tomás de Aquino,
admiraron y adoptaron
su enfoque sobre las virtudes
y hay similitudes entre la ataraxia
estoica, o la tranquilidad de la mente,
y el concepto budista de nirvana.
Un estoico particularmente influyente
fue el filósofo Epicteto
que escribió que el sufrimiento no deriva
de los acontecimientos de nuestras vidas,
sino de nuestros juicios sobre ellos.
Esto ha resonado fuertemente
en la psicología moderna
y el movimiento de autoayuda.
Por ejemplo, la terapia
racional emotiva conductual
se centra en cambiar
las actitudes autodestructivas
que la gente expresa frente
a sus circunstancias en la vida.
También está la logoterapia
de Viktor Frankl.
Desarrollada por el propio Frankl
en base a su experiencia como prisionero
en un campo de concentración,
la logoterapia se rige
por el principio estoico
de que podemos usar
nuestra fuerza de voluntad
para dar sentido a nuestras vidas
incluso en las situaciones más sombrías.